three two one
hello how's it going how's it going
everybody
hope you're having a good week we are
here for
another round of corporate chess league
and hopefully this is going to be a very
very exciting round um
i'm pretty excited because it's the
first time i'm doing it alone
and i am also pretty excited because i
get to pick a winner the best game
prize so
those are my reasons and i've also i've
been looking into the corporate chess
league for a while now and
i think it's just such an interesting
idea that everybody
is playing with each other i wish i
could actually see it
in person but unfortunately we
are in working from home
but well safety comes first right
so i am very excited to
have these games start playing
and i am waiting for
some of the players to just start
and
i wish i could show you some
rosters but
i am still not seeing anybody play
which is a little unfortunate for me
been waiting still want to see you guys
play
um i thought games would start
about a minute ago but i still can't see
any of the games let me try to refresh
my page
maybe that's an issue that i'm having
nope still nobody oh boy
well there might be some slight
technical
difficulties trying to start the games
thank you thank you it's a fun
background huh welcome welcome to studio
d
studio door stuff from home all right
i am still kind of hopeful that
i'm gonna get at least the game over
here nope
um so i
am still gameless waiting for
um i still i'm probably gonna start
texting
around to see what is going on i was
excited to start talking and immediately
start showing games
i really want to talk about games right
now
my blood chest levels are
dropping oh boy
um no i still
do not see oh i see great
well actually i can't follow so
not too great ah
lovely well not no problem from my end
because i
am already experiencing slight internet
issues since the storm two days ago
my wi-fi has been very playful keeps
going at every half an hour for like 10
seconds
coffee break maybe a smoke break not
sure
so i can't even really watch netflix
without interruption
but let alone play chess i have to be
careful
time my games all right i'm gonna keep
uh hoping to see some oh
i have one playing yay all right
i am going to um
start showing you the game okay
so this is the first game
that i managed to catch it's a game
between
um let me double check
oh this is the game between um
edward jones team and the
buyers team so that is pretty exciting
uh let's see so eagle eye
is from buyer's
team buyer sorry so he's black so edward
jones is
white this is black we got an
interesting
pyrrhic defense i actually play this
line i usually play it with like
f3 and long castle bishop g5 bishop e3
interesting there's like a little trick
with knight g4 here i actually had a
very nice game and that's in abu dhabi
tournament 20
i want to say 15 or yeah probably 15.
so i'm gonna hope
for gonna try and find another game
another of the players
um i can see that in this game black is
already
um trying to
figure out what to do hopefully that's
gonna give me enough time to find
another oh we have another player great
now if i could only figure out how to
close that board
okay so this game is pretty advanced
already
so this is a game between
again uh edward jones and
beyer so this should be
edward jones is
white i believe yeah so we got a
nice fianchetto on the board
going after the bishop oh not sure
fisher before was the best
move but i like the idea of knight f3
that knight on e4 is pretty annoying i
wish to kind of kick it away maybe
okay knight d2 maybe white could try for
e4 there we go
take take on d5 hmm
um i i'm not the biggest one
taking over here i'm thinking maybe we
could try like
c4 and kick the knight away maybe knight
b4 and then try to take on b7
i can understand why this pawn would not
be very desirable
so okay this should be
four oh queenish five let's see what's
the idea behind that
um maybe try to look at d5
but let's say take on c3 rook d8
defending the pawn
oh i'm not the biggest fan of queen d1
maybe there could be like a rookie one
trying to like double up the rooks play
rook a7
activity activity and
okay so we got that one isolated pawn
all right so finally doubled up with the
rook and this
is the position let's uh so far i think
this position is interesting
but i don't really
i think white has the activity so that
could be
a big factor now let's
look for someone else
um i'm gonna look for
another game
okay so this is the game of
the um
again still between edward jones and
fire
this is
so how to what to think about this
position i mean first glance i like
white more
so white is
the alex carfort person
and i believe there has there's some
nice videos that hopefully
are included in this
and oh boy
i trying to get to see
myself on youtube to just double check
if everything's going smooth i'm sure it
is but
you know i've been having some slight
paranoia about
my connections anyways
all right i seem to be going well okay
so uh besides the paranoia this is a
very interesting game
i first for per second i thought it was
from stonewalls but this is the
dash defense let's recap really quick
okay so far everything going good i
understand b3 you gotta get that bishop
off
maybe it was interesting to try for
bishop a3 maybe like a4 bishop a3
because
this is the bad bishop but this is a
good bishop so it would be good to
exchange those
all right so now white's got better
[Music]
let me know which of a3 trying to kick
that rook around a little
all right knight e5 i understand that
okay now i definitely prefer white this
bishop
is just it's looking painful man
oh god e4 yeah this is much much better
for white
there should be something really fast
just attacking on h7
just if i could if i could um there's a
rook f8
idea too so if i could double up the
rooks the game would be pretty done
already maybe the idea of like playing
queen d3
and then trying to just slowly slowly
look after your kf1
yeah i like that idea that rook capture
is also threatening rock history yeah i
think this game is in favor of white
i already like this game so
um i kind of want to look at another
team
maybe we could take a look at
um i feel like i'm going in order
but it's okay um i like
to look at games as much as games
possible
let's search for this one
oh boy not popping up huh
let's go back to the first game to look
at the development
on how it turned out while i bring up
another game
um
how about
yeah i kind of want to look at someone
else's game maybe
ah i worked with this kid before maybe
we can look at
this game
oh boy why isn't it showing me games
oh no i want to see games
oh that is not good news
um everything is going smoothly except i
can't load games
i'm gonna try one more time before i
officially
feel slight panic
oh
no it's not allowing me to load any more
games
why let me try to close
one tab maybe that will help
no that's still not helping oh boy
technical issues
it's time for commentary i
am loading up the games
as soon as i can um
yes i am here chess.com let me just do
the little
reload over here that should help
yeah um
i i have three games open i'm working on
those i
wanna see more games come on chess.com
let me see more games
all right while i am trying to
um figure this out let's just focus on
the game that's
it's in front of us and this is the game
the french game french defense game that
we looked at
pretty quickly and i
yeah i'm not so um
crazy about this position but i feel
white is more comfortable
just because the knights the knight has
too many squares yeah exactly the other
knight is also jumping to c5
and um
yeah so let's see what else can we do
well uh
we got this night
to c5
okay i think this is a very positional
game i'm more
curious on what's happening in this
dutch defense
white seems to be doing very well
actually rook f8 right
we're gonna fight this mate huh
come on white you can do this
so far i like this game but i haven't
seen enough games to make the decision
you know i'm
still working towards
i think this game should be a win pretty
quick so
i'm gonna go look at the other one that
we
had open
um
all right i'm still unfortunately unable
to look
at usernames so i might have to have to
go down
manually and try to check
um
this is a very interesting position now
this pawn on e6 looks to be
very deadly because if you take it back
i'll just take it with the queen and
what are you gonna do queen e7
can i just play like rookie one
i like this position for white all right
i need a second to try and
reload so uh
let me try and reload over here
hopefully now we can get to see even
more games
[Music]
it's not allowing me to watch games
maybe this will okay
oh nope that does not help me
in any way or shape oops
uh
it's ah i hate technical difficulties
i need real life over the board chess
okay um oh no white didn't do the mate
over here
you remember guys i was talking about
mates hurricane f8 mates
oh oh oh this would have been such a
beautiful mate
ouch well this is still pretty winning
for whites regardless
now h7 is still made rook f8 is made
so i don't think black is gonna get away
with this
but kind of painful not to be able to
have that fast mate
oh boy all right let me just show you
what i'm talking about i still have
failed to
load more games than this tree but
in this one this is the one i was
talking about that's rook f8
you know here but if forgive
eight that would be mate but
unfortunately white played
queen d3 trying to go after mate on h7
and this uh still white is winning just
not mate in two anymore
and um
all right i am
going to try and
look for another username hopefully
it won't fight with me
so
no it's still not letting me
could try to look for it manually but
there are way too many games for me to
try and
find um let me try again
okay let's try to close out of this game
this is a pretty
oh that game okay so we actually have a
new game that is nice
so the previous game um alex managed to
win
the the dutch defense so now he has
started a new game
which is good for us we have something
else to look at
this position is the one with e6 i'm
going to try and close
this tab
[Music]
and um so hopefully we can get
some new games and after e6 but this
actually happened
take take bishop g6 all right this is a
more comfortable end game for
white definitely so far but something
went wrong
probably here i don't think
um i don't think something like bishop
d3 was the most accurate
maybe maybe rookie won first
whoa nope not the exact position i was
talking about
but oh that's such a beautiful position
maybe not ricky one first and then try
bishop d3 because when you play bishop
dt
first then you get queen e7 i still
don't think you should exchange queen's
juice i think you still should play like
queen f4 and then try to do knight e5
but all right so let me switch to
another game and
close this one in hopes of being able to
open
a new one which still
was too hopeful okay
i kind of need more games so i'm gonna
switch you guys
back to full face while i
actually close chess.com all together
and reopen it
oh boy hopefully this will
work great
uh okay i feel
like i'm walking into an exam slightly
nervous because
i don't like technical difficulties but
then again who does
so all right let's go to
live chess
all right so i still have these two here
let me try to look for another one
come on show me the username
no i
don't understand why
all right well i i'm sure
we can get help soon
while that's going on i'm going to still
share the layout with you guys
so you can at least see the game
that i'm seeing um so
this is this was an interesting opening
um i've actually had a recent student
who played this bird's defense
well opening some people call it burst
attack burst defense
with me so yeah that has been pretty
interesting
but i don't really do this style i try
to do like g6 bishop g7
some um seems to confuse people pretty
much
so
[Music]
all right what else do we have here
i'm gonna switch back to the other game
so we can
enjoy the limited variety available
oh man all right so um
we looked at this game earlier but this
here now
black is just has way too many pawns
yeah black should be winning
pretty smoothly
let me try for whoops another game
um
so
[Music]
i am still kind of hopeful i'll get
to see more games all right i can't
probably find this username
hopefully i don't like to
hope too much i like to see games i want
to see games
uh but it's just
doesn't make any sense
all right well this game is going as
predicted black is definitely winning
now let's look at the other game and
um
trying to look for the usernames
manually but
since they're based on rating that is
not
actually working
oh man all right
um
well this game did go as predicted and
um black one we
might have to take a small
break for me to figure out with some
i.t help on why we can't view these
games
maybe if i change browsers it'll help
but all right so uh please hang around
we will be back very shortly i just need
a slight bit of more help to view some
games okay so um
i am going to click and stream don't go
anywhere
we will be back very shortly to see more
game
all right great we are back uh it was a
slight issue that
something was not working but we figured
it out
and we're just in time to see someone
score full point
interesting so um this game was between
this two teams of
um i believe this was
the weights
weights was wwt which
wwt would be
playing with enterprise so that was an
interesting win
for wwt
player so let's try and look at as many
games possible because
i am excited that i can finally see some
games
okay so woohoo
it is working great so how about this
game
this game is still between those two
teams
and um
whoa what is going on here
we got a car wreck on g4
all right trying to trap the bishop
exchanging the bishops
so far so good logical trying to get
knight b5 stopping it okay
makes sense knight f3 what is the idea
like knight f3 i'm kind of hoping for
f5 soon all right i understand b4 but
um b4 kind of gets a little
makes me a little um worried about
potential takes but not right now just
right now
um i'm hoping to be like
i'm hoping something like queen b6 and
a5 because if take right now then pawn
takes back queen takes back ah there we
go queen v6 was played over the board
and okay i am kind of curious
um to see
how can we
go for another game
all right so we are still looking at the
same team
and if i am i believe
uh it's it's not like um so
usually when we're playing team
tournaments uh either
everybody is white then the same team or
everybody is black in the same team
which uh well since we're censored like
everybody's playing
two games with um within us like those
two teams are playing two games against
each other
because perf makes perfect sense to me
but the way
i've been playing uh teams and leagues
growing up it was only one game against
one opponent
and when the team was white the first
board was white second word was black he
was
formatted like that but all right so
um this game is actually uh
i'm still kind of
excited to see how this one is going all
right i like this idea of b4
interesting choice for black
and maybe white would do like e4 e5s at
some points that would be really good
okay queen a4 also nice attacking a6 and
c6
understandable okay white's winning a
pawn
ooh and that was
not a good choice to take on d6
yeah cause after taking on b6 now
these poor guys are both under attack
and can't be helped all right this
position is very comfortable for light
i am quite certain whites can
work this out and uh white has already
won
one of the two games and this is the
second one so
oh boy all right let's look at um
i think i believe this was one of the
games between edward jones
and um buyers
buyer no s oh boy
all right so actually how is this
position going
i kinda think this is um so
knock on woods knock on woods is
edward's jones
and knock on i thought that was a middle
eastern expression until i actually
moved here and i realized oh no that's
actually
a very global expression of knocking on
wood
so anyways um knock on wood
won the first game but the second game
doesn't seem to be going so well for him
this attack on the king is pretty deadly
um just probably
even i think taking over here white is
doing much better just because of the
three extra pawns so unfortunately this
doesn't seem to be going on knock on
wood's way
alright i am excited to see another game
so let's just keep scrolling through
um let's look at the games between
mark martz and dix
express scripts those are three games
that i am excited
to find and see now that i can't find
games
all right actually it doesn't seem i
think
would at least one of the players are
not have finished their games so that is
not good news for me but maybe i get
lucky and i can find another player on
that team
okay we found another player so
this seems to be um
that black has already won one of the
games
this is the second match so
i believe this would mean
that this express scripts
have more points what is going on in
this position it's a very positional
play
knight vs bishop now um
i kind of smell like white because i
don't really know what
where exactly to place this this um
knight
i do know that on g6 it's not doing much
so it would be much better if this
knight is
located somewhere else not entirely sure
exactly where though
maybe black would try to poke something
maybe like with b5 or c5 and try to get
the knight over there
or i um
i mean i understand that if now take
take
knight to e7 attacking f5 but taking on
a2
i think black is doing better honestly
at this point
let's look at another game
actually nope that game is actually
finished already wanted to see
all right so let's try to look
at another
team completely
nope how about this team
[Music]
oh no that game is also finished
um let's
hope for another one games are finishing
so fast
oh nope that is also finished well we
can still look
for this game which was um
i believe one of the games between
um daughter
daughter whoa
i need to update my knowledge of
corporates
being a pre-med does not help and
versus extras um
what is going on here white seems to be
a little bit
more um a little bit more
space advantage but at the same time
black is doing okay because of this
strong pawn structure
so i guess um
one of the things lights would
definitely do is like bishop v3 try to
get like a knight d4
block these pawns and start trying to
make something happen in the
center kingside
so that is one of my suggestions
on what to do in this position
but all right let's see
what else can we think about
um
this is a very interesting game
let me try to actually see if i can find
another game
too
so we can switch back and forth because
my luck every game oh this game i can
watch every game i've been trying to
watch so far
in the past minute or two they have been
unfortunately
well maybe fortunately already done
playing the boat games ooh this is this
looks kind of painful
for black ouch c7 pawn is falling then
d6 coming the queen oh boy
yeah yeah that doesn't
that looks quite painful
all right let's see
what's our other extras doing here
oh i guess we have oh
no unfortunately that game was also
finished but i'll be sure to check that
username
again don't want to give up who i just
checked because i wanted to keep some
surprises hopefully but all right so let
me uh just
roll back to this game for a second um
i kind of like white more even though
black
ate that a2 pawn earlier but white's
activity is very
very interesting and this knight here is
looking pretty um
unpleasant so maybe if well maybe like
white could do like a queen c7 rook d7
that would be very interesting to get
the seventh rank start attacking some
pawns
i kind of like that idea i don't think
white should touch any of these pawns
not just yet
but i do think white should try and
bring her up to the seventh rank
especially with queen v8 because if
queen beat queen d queen
um sorry queen c7 if queen b8 then you
can still do rook d7 attack b7
have an eye on these i also don't think
you should take because if take then the
knights also getting activated either
from
oops not taking with pawn because if
take with pawn
yeah if you want take with pawn take
back oh no oh no i don't think g4 was a
good idea
i was hoping take if take it pawn maybe
bishop v6
i was trying to explain that but i still
firmly believe that
we should just attack
on the seventh rank this game
white won where did all the pawns go
there were more pawns here ah white just
gave the pawns up to
advance one pawn all right makes sense
i'm i can understand that strategy
this game was another game that i was oh
no i thought white could pull this off
we were looking at it somewhere here and
i was saying we should do like this
bishop e3 knight d4
oh but wow black lights very neatly
knight h6 tanking over f5 square and e3
and d4
very nice nicely done by black so far
and now oh rook g5
yeah unfortunately after losing e5 these
two pawns
are very strong whoa not those two these
two
and then d3 coming up yeah i
i think white has seen better better
times all right
i'm gonna try and find
some new games hopefully
but according to the score sheet
most of the players have already
completed their two games
which makes it hard for me to find games
but well
i am glad so far we've had
these few games
and all right let me try for this one
nah just online okay so i actually think
these two
are the last two games remaining from
this round
let me also take a look at our youtube
oh yeah alex skirford i was looking at
your game it was a
it was uh as black stalling at this
queen
so that was a very interesting game i
remember that game i was looking at both
of your games the first one
i i think you were the one who had the
rookie of eight mate
in the the dutch one that was a very
good game
um
yeah the other one i
i thought wasn't going so well
unfortunately for you but let me
double check before oh no it actually
went well never mind never mind my bad
sorry i
hopefully all right so this game is also
done
with a beautiful win for black i think
this is one of my
favorite games so far this was a good
quite a beautiful game black
had some really interesting strategic
ideas
what about this game how's this game
going after g4
all right that knight on h8 is still
pretty sad oh no
bishop d5
hopefully bishop d5 sometime
this would have been way better now the
bishop all right actually this is still
going all right trying to eat some ponds
i am a big fan of eating ponds
all right i think this is actually the
last game of the round
looking at scoresheet this seems to be
the
the last one whoa all right
so how is this going i think this is uh
i
much prefer to be white especially now
that the b7 pawn is falling
i just kind of hope that we had the king
a little bit closer maybe on like
already f5 or on d4
that would have been more beautiful i
remember
in my in the camps with some of the
kids over the last week or two we have
been doing
a lot of these um a lot of this
different end games with like when to
try and exchange the rooks how to
convert the advantage
and that has been i'm
it's kind of nice to see what i've been
teaching recently happened
in some of these games
i think it would be kind of
um i wish this light was already on a5
then whites would have an easier
game but laura let's see is it time to
push for e5
the problem is that if you play e5 after
take oops after take take um
the you kind of even like the knight
could sacrifice the
itself for just one of the the last pawn
standing
in the center and that's uh you can't
really promote your pawn
because your bishop isn't the same color
as
where your pawn would promote right
whoops
so you shouldn't really you shouldn't
push this pawn you shouldn't exchange
these
oh but at the same time if you don't
well actually what if knight f4 now oh
no this is gonna end in a draw
white was doing so interesting i really
enjoyed that position
oh boy um
well actually i take it back um
white unfortunately made a mistake
now e7 knight takes e7 king takes e7
and this pawn would be running
so
oh no whoa this game is all over the
place man
wow i'm quite intrigued
well now black on
can't really stop the queening
i was gonna call that baby queen but
that's uh it's
not a baby goodness it's the there we go
it's a full queen
just trying a bunch of checks maybe a
queen f8 trying to take
h6 queen d6 let's take on h6
just take on h6 and try to promote the
other pawn
it's the easiest way especially since
white has so little time
good thing there's increments right
take that take that never mind is it
i thought there was a delay
well thank you alex all right gotta
bring the king bring the king fast fast
just promote
pre-move king e5 king e5
king d4 pre-move pre-move king e3
there you go take on f2 pre-move have
that pre-moved
start chasing queen f4 or that works too
just put that queen on f5
oh that works too then just put the king
on f6 free move
and you got mate on the board next move
oh hello thank you thank you wilson
family
uh teacherman22 all right i'll be sure
to check
that as well all right um
kind of curious are there any games
remaining because i could not actually
find
any players playing i just saw there
were a lot of players online
so i could take another look
at some of the games that we missed
probably but
um i really want to be able to show
the score so i'm hoping
to just maybe
we could share the score sheet or
i can actually tell you the results that
i see here as well
so from what i see
um edward jones
beat the won the first round against
um buyer enterprise
scores are higher compared to
wwt so day one as well
um mariot's versus express
scripts scores are
closer but mars one according to what
i'm seeing
[Music]
and
i'm still looking for
all right i think the final scores are
also put in
um i believe extras also
um one versus
uh
yeah day one i'm sorry i was just a
little confused because um
i thought the uh teacher man 22 on the
dvora's jones
but i see it here in extras so
that slightly confused me but i guess
extras do belong to different teams but
i'm that is something for me to learn
for next time on how the extras
work probably all right oh is that ryan
chester i see
i see archester st lcc
well interesting all right um
i am going to actually
see if we can
share the scoresheet because i kind of
really want to
so fine
yeah well
all right i'm still standing by for a
confirmation
but let's me ah
all right never mind now okay i think i
understand the concept of extras better
now
probably the whole idea was the people
who were extra in the team were just
form a team that's actually a nice idea
not that they would kind of
let it happen in
um all right so hopefully we can see
this screen oh to some extent
let me just share my webcam for a second
while i load that
[Music]
um
okay um
yeah i think
well we could share this is um
i am a little uncomfortable about the
layouts
i am a newbie in streaming
without someone telling me exactly what
to do
um
ah there is a fourth string all right
that actually does
help so let me
see if that works oh boy nope that does
not work
oh no not entirely sure why it doesn't
work
actually
um i would like to share the standings
so ah i understand why it doesn't work
that was in a different tab
well that is my bad okay so
this uh these are the standings after
the first round
edward jones is leading with 33 points
enterprise is just
our first runner up with 27
points um
marit's 24 points
and i was kind of curious to see where
the extras but
well i guess extras wouldn't
be actually called extras here but okay
so yeah these are very interesting
games going on and all right
uh we have three other
three teams that i'll
wish them all the best in the second
round gotta get more points guys
i'm here i'm rooting for you we need
everybody to be double digits
and yeah uh this has been a pretty
interesting
turn of events so far but edward jones
also has a lot of players
they're doing pretty well so
uh i don't think it's that unexpected
but alright so let me just switch tabs
back to chess stuff
and okay so
uh next ground is starting very soon
hopefully everybody is ready
and it's going to be very exciting
i actually i kind of wanted to
check this one game out
if it doesn't kick me off because i open
the new tab on chess.com
the one thing that i actually feel
uncomfortable
when i'm on chess.com is when i i'm used
to opening new tabs
not just working within the same tab so
i accidentally open new tabs and then
chess.com kicks me out and then i'm like
no
why did this happen so yeah that's been
one of my biggest issues with chess.com
so guys be careful
don't learn from me don't yeah exactly
just told me another login detected
oh boy well um
so so far this has been a very
interesting
event i'm ready for round two
round two uh enterprise is playing
edward
jones um buyer
is playing uh oh boy
hard pronunciation for me coming up i
want to say daughtery
but i i'm horrible with pronunciations
anyone who knows me knows that so
i apologize in advance for all of the
mispronunciations that's going to happen
then we have wwt playing against
mart and then we have express scripts
playing versus extras
and all right well that's going to be an
exciting
uh i was going to say 20 games but i
guess
it's doubled so a lot of games
40 probably maybe a little bit even more
yeah so far going great slight technical
issues
technical difficulties but in this day
and age
nothing unexpected
all right um i'm gonna start
following some games some usernames so
i am already
i kind of wanted to check this one game
[Music]
that was mentioned to me
yeah while you're waiting why not let's
go check out this game
let me switch back so um
alex if you're still here i went to
check your game
so this was the white game oh yeah all
right proud of my memory this was the
rf8 game that i was mentioning
all right i am quite proud of
remembering this is a beautiful game
then i wanted to look at this game
oh wow i don't really want the analysis
or the accuracy just want to see the
game oh no
my layout is needs slight adjustments
all right i guess that's um okay for
right now
and we'll make it look even better
afterwards whoa what is going on here
oh yeah that's the game that um
we were looking at this game looks very
unfamiliar for me is this the game we
were looking at
now i'm a little confused
and
ha it was well
okay i have the game loaded
and actually the next round is starting
so i'm gonna go ahead and
close this part up be ready to start
looking
for the new players
nope still not still not playing
so i'm just gonna have my usernames
right here
oh well i have one online
[Music]
oh wait
let's hope oh yeah we have we have
um mr wilson's game on the board let's
see how this is going well hopefully
you're listening in eli
oh bishop f2 this
doesn't seem to be going where hold on
so we had a
normal french happening dwight just
tries to castle
and black just takes king f3
ho ho um i
don't understand why not just king j1
and then you could like push h3
kick that knight away and just play king
h2 i think that's actually pretty safe
king him does worry me a lot oh boy
oh mama all right it's king f3 what do
you want to do with that king
um you got to develop like next move has
to be d4
because now queen f6 check is coming up
oh mama or queen d5
king has to go to f4 oh no
g5 or queen five oh cool
all right this was a quick turn of
events
well they started a new game so let's
keep watching oh no
alright
so i have
slightly messed up my
streaming style whoops
but this should be going alright right
okay so let me find another game while
we
are watching this game
so i could actually readjust my tab
because all right apologize for this
slight
uh disfiguration of the tabs that you
are
witnessing right about now there you go
all right nothing to worry about
it's a very quick adjustment just
working on it all right there we go this
should be okay now
just let me get the name two
ah all right there we go oh wasn't that
bad now was it
all right so let's see what do we have
here
so wow it seems like
george jones um edward jose's
alex already won the first round wow i'm
one of these rates am i already late to
the second round first game whoa you
guys play
fast man so let's take a quick look at
this kohler
stonewall style maybe throwing that
knight on e5
soon enough all right
i i think this is still going well let's
take a look
at this game unfortunately
um teacher man had suffered
quite unfortunate loss the previous game
the first round of this tournament the
sorry first round of the second round
let's go with that huh
so um
this seems to be going on right now wow
both games were french
all right now develop
guys develop get that knight out castle
join a c5
still should be good moves right keep
the king safe
okay i want to go look at another team
real quick
i am kind of i am
i kind of want to go see how is our
chester doing
how are you doing garchester
so
what's going on in this position these
three pawns
are looking sharp huh
be careful not to do e4 because your f4
square is going to be
quite unhappy what was the opening
all right roy lopez
whoa i actually do play this queen d2
good choice of opening archester
okay getting some pieces out
everything seems to be going all right
okay i i think this is a very
interesting position a lot of good
fighting chances
interesting ideas hopefully there will
be a d4 soon
too okay now let's look
at another
team as well
i kind of want to see how is wwt doing
because i wanted to see their games last
round and i just couldn't find them they
kept
they finished their games way before i
got there
you guys are playing very fast so far
most of the games that i've seen have
already had
uh the first game of the second round
completed alright so
so you guys have just started playing
this
okay maybe get that maybe pawn c3
defend be careful not to take because
the b2 square is going to be quite
painful what else do we have
there's a king dennis i kind of want to
go see how is king
dennis doing
whoa that's a beautiful night right
there
i think so far this is
going in favor of king dennis
that is bad news for teacher man
but i have to say so far the two games
i've seen from
king dennis versus t-shirt those two
have been
so far my favorites
they've been very tactical especially
this one
this one also the idea of just castling
and knight g5 going after
kind of a kind of ironic the first game
um black the king tennis also went for
the f2 square remember
took on f2 and did whoops took on f2
and did those knights g4 style but
now very interesting
oh boy what else do we
got um
[Music]
let's look at
kamikaze knight i kind of want to check
that
with knock on woods
i do like those usernames
all right so
oh we have a new viewer as well
um he has been present in most of my
classes and streams and now he is
um witnessing the corporate chess league
it's a interesting turn of events
not used to my catch cat watching me
stream or play chess
all right so what is going on over here
i think white's doing better but not
because
of um i think just because of the
development
this bishop some ideas with bishop c7
maybe by kicking
this a5 kicking the queen around a
little maybe a knight a4 oh
just did a5 i was kind of thinking about
maybe a5 a little bit later
but i guess this also works okay uh
this game is finished and
well it's a beautiful position on the
board
sorry teacher man
all right i'm gonna load another game
hopefully
um let's look at
fishers kind of look at the username of
fishers of man
is a great username huh
oh no they've already completed their
games only online oh boy
i'm beginning to um
fall behind on who is winning and who is
not
all right let's take a look at another
team
oh plank great whoa
what is happening here well good for me
they haven't completed their first
game yet just in time for
the first game but white is doing much
better
yeah white's position is much more
pleasant
it's um attacking more has more material
yeah the pass pawn too
yeah this is this is much better for
white
all right let's look at another position
okay thankfully for me
there is an abundant of them not like
earlier when they're like i was stuck on
two games couldn't find any
i don't know a lot of technology like i
i'm a big fan of technology i believe
that technology does help our lives
and there are some questions about
whether or not
uh but the ais and take over and stuff
like that but
not thinking about those just thinking
about technology i think it's great
but those little glitches and the fact
that we still need other humans to help
us through the technology
those are still kind of
going yeah exactly exactly so we have a
new viewer
so only if you could actually log into
youtube for himself
actually what's going on here i'm
thinking and looking at this board i'm
thinking and i still can't figure out
how is white winning just because of the
knight that's
under attack maybe like just because you
gotta move the queen and then you lose
the knight i guess that's just enough
for a win
yeah how did this happen
it's still pretty early on in the game
oh c6 lovely
oh boy develop develop develop
i understand the concept of like trying
to sacrifice
but no boy
knight d5 looks five kind of wrongs
i don't think take is that bad
but can you just take on g5
[Music]
that looks that looks pretty appealing
to me
oh yeah all right i can see why
this happened also take don't give up
free material
eat back take that night and yes
you're not going to have a super great
castle but you can just
play queen f6 and then push for that
yeah now this is unfortunately pretty
lost for white
sorry for black but could have been
pretty lost for white if black just took
the pieces oh boy alright
let's look at another game
now how is
um
okay plank great
so oh is that a cat or a dog in the
picture
oh that is a painful position
so white is most likely going to win
this game
and so white
is uh the team buyer
versus
still waiting for oh never mind
so yes this is the team this is the
buyer team
versus
darty
i g4
alright so buyer is
winning this game
and i believe this game was
also buyer was white let me just double
check on that
um yeah so
interesting
oh nope kind of
just kind of hoping to see some updated
score so i could
read them out loud but well
i want to go back and see how is
our chester dealing oh rorchester is
doing great
well good job this is going pretty well
right
so this should be this should be um
swiftly done for our chester
how is alex kurfort
doing versus big daddy jazz 64.
well this is a interesting position
this pawn is very under pressure
so is d4 pawn so i guess it's kind of
the fight between who is going to win
which one faster
um i don't really know how to get away
from this maybe white could try like an
h3 kh2
maybe oh maybe not like a bishop e2
bishop f3
was just saying bishop to bishop f3
while when white just
put the bishop on f1 now what
um oh if there was a bishop e2 the
bishop h5 is almost also a threat
it's not too late come back still play
the chevy 2.
if you want to swift the bishop to h5
ah yes yes i i had the impression that
was you ryan chester
good game it was quite a beautiful game
all right now we have another game
happening
ooh french you know i want to see a
scotch game over here no one's playing
scotch
or events i need to see some scotch
or maybe like the um
e4 c5 knight c3 grand prix style
all right so the game between kamikaze
and
knock on woods the first game was
ended in a draw wow
i thought white was doing better
ah oh no white waited too long
maybe white should have played um
something on
d6 no maybe that would have been more
interesting we like a bishop d6
ah it is also um the guys
are the the players right now can't
um play themselves which
is yeah the challenge button have been
failing
i see that from multiple
players all right i think this is solved
all right great
i see knock on woods was able to
challenge
rematch kamikaze
and
alright well that's good news i've had
technical difficulties
for the day i successfully give myself
that prize
but yeah i still seriously have to find
a game that
i absolutely liked the second or second
round second game between king dennis
and um king dennis and
the teacherman 22 i like that but i i
just feel like i need to see more games
that i like that because it was so
tactical
and kind of ironic on how things were
happening on f2 and f7
but well we can still try to figure out
more games right all right i still
don't see an updated score sheet
so i can't know who is done playing
unfortunately but there was this one
other person
that i really wanted to check again
ah king take all right let's go let's
see how's king take her doing
hopefully he has taken a few kings
in one of oh yeah he's still playing
great in
one of the camps um
oh king takert has won his first game
good job
it's kind of funny in one of the camps i
was trying to tell the kids like how can
we trap the king
and they were like so are we trying to
actually
win the king and i was like not exactly
and i was trying to tell them like trap
it without giving a check
but you don't have to like just drop it
and go come back for it later and the
whole concept was kind of interesting so
tink
dig the id king taker
that's also another interesting id
maybe king trapper would be cool too now
c6 is
facing a big issue so
i think white's doing good in this
situation
yeah what's doing all right now d7 under
attack
a8 under attack probably the best move
is like rook d8
which is um
still kind of unpleasant
maybe then black white could just take
on d7 because if you take back maybe
just do like your rp8
yeah take take ba to free cafe take take
i think that's that would be nice
let's look at another game how did
oh no alex lost well
this was quite a hard game i just
probably a little bit of miscalculations
over here because white is having
a better position oh no
little tactics oh boy
well maybe throw in a maybe next game
try and like try and do this like a
little h3 to open the
little leeway for the king and then do
the bishop d3s
yeah those are always kind of hurtful
finally got a good position finally got
your extra material oh yeah
well the first game was pretty nice
though
this one you also had a good chance just
a little bit of tactic
yeah yeah probably s3 would have been
more interesting but also while you're
here i was thinking when you played
bishop f1 it was a nice idea to defend
g2 and attack d4
maybe it was also um interesting to look
for like
bishop e2 because you were thinking
about bishop h5
and maybe also bishop f3 to just
completely cut this bishop
i thought that was also interesting so
some ideas to think about all right i
want to see
how mr chester is doing
oh that's a very interesting position
oh rook c1 no no don't think about just
put the rock on c1
right away thank you thank you alex
put the rock on c1 then you can push
like b4 knight b3
knight c5 there we go
alright so this is an interesting game
oh i want to see this
game in time trouble
how is this going well white seems to be
having
a really fun time
right put like a rook on f1 drive it
d4 even well this seems to be going ah
there we go d4 this seems to be going
in white's favor how about this game
i believe these games are from
um oh i was
mistaken i thought i was good looking at
the wwt
games team games
let's me ah this
this is a game
between steve
r19 and david chopin
and the teams would be
steve is for mart's and david is for wwt
i like it when it's normal names when
it's like
mjc or km i always have to
look like this try to figure out the
name
it makes me feel like i need glasses
all right so how's this going i think
black's doing pretty fine right
the psap knight on d4 yeah this seems to
be going
a lot better for black
so i'm going to look at another game
from the same team hopefully they
haven't already finished their games
it's good to finish the games but you
know i also wanna
get a chance to comment on thank you for
not finishing your game
oh i'm right whoa that is
very interesting so this game is between
the same teams
of wwt
and uh maritz
so that's kind of i'm pretty
i mean i like this it seems to be going
pretty well
right
um
just have to be quite careful okay never
mind you got maintain one
all right i was a little worried about
if
um black just tried to play like the
king
get the king out in the center but all
right beautiful win beautiful
end game win for i am rounder
very interesting game i very much like
the end game let me just take a quick
look at
the opening and the middle game to see
if this game is becoming
one of my favorites
oh
oh no just a just a night blunder oh boy
all right well i i enjoyed the endgame
very much
very great technique okay
let's take a look at knock on woods on
kamikaze
how is this going maybe like a c4
to be soon
um i really wish this knight was already
out
or maybe like a knight eight three
knight b5 well the f4 is under attack so
i have to keep that in mind too
[Music]
maybe i mean knight d4
but i don't really like knight d4
because it blocks the bishop so if
knight d4
then your ideas with c4 and opening the
bishop are kind of
not really as
good anymore
let me see let's look at another game
so this is a game from the same team of
wwt and
maritz so let's see how is this going
this so far oh boy
so black has black is
exchanged down but
has more activity for it
all right we can we can take a super
quick look from beginning right scotch
oh no
oh boy all right this is interesting
vienna okay join f4
do this oh too late now well
still going all right um
i i'm thinking maybe knight e4 was a
little too early
night because now yeah i think
still f4 should be at least
considered because f4 if take take
with the knight and then knight e4 yeah
i think
you gotta do this f4 anyways ooh black
is forming a very nice attack
okay bishop d2 oh was that a blunder
maybe uh maybe f4 first then rook h6 or
maybe g5 first and rock f strict h6
oh no well black is still holding
and threatening still bringing pieces
okay let's see how is this going
oh there there there
well now black is better
because if you were to
um this knight f1 kind of
made it a little
gave black some chances
this is actually much better for black
now
hold on what if i was thinking what if
just bishop e3
just putting more pressure or what if
like d3
so i don't i don't really think this is
going so well for white anymore
oh boy
so okay let's take another look i
wanna see how is our chest are doing
so actually this is going pretty well
for him
um still a piece up
still up on after looking good
how did that punk get on f3 ah wow that
was
that spawn has been on f3 for so long
whoa one check there oh
this looks like it should be done right
now
how did it get how did it go so far
maybe oh maybe bishop e2
check hi like this rook c8
oh take one
maybe it would be better to do like rook
c8
king b2 than like queen c3 or like
bishop c4
i think this would have been more
interesting
so okay this seems to be going all right
for
mr chester going strong
i still don't have an update on the
scores
so hopefully that's going to
get
all right so anyways i want to look at
another game while i'm waiting
to see how that's going one
i was interested in another username
[Music]
let's check that out
oh never mind just realized i was
actually looking at it
i was trying to look at some of the
people that i might know by
last name and well just realized
they're both here never mind never mind
so let's look let's try to see who
else can we play
hmm
well actually most of the teams are
already
most of the players have already
completed their two games
which is slightly unfortunate for me let
me still just
keep looking for some new games
oh no well when this game is
already done i'll just randomly start
going through the teams should be able
to find someone
right nope still online
oh whoa well one by timeout but this
position is actually much better for
black anyways well i know having a queen
always helps
so while we are looking for me to find
to go down and hunt some of the players
who
are still playing let's look at this
game oh
black has a very nice technique right
now actually this is my favorite game
let's see how
it turns out whoa white brought the king
out
so fast that king just went all the way
from
h1 being all the way trapped to b5
unfortunately it's not enough though now
that black is
easily going to win wait the king is
coming back
okay the king is still caught let's see
how this turns out
still curious but um there was some
really nice technique for black the way
that black just got that bishop to f3
that was
really great good job
um
[Music]
come on black you gotta cut the king cut
the king no not there your rook was good
on f6 put the rook back on f6 well i
guess that's also okay
but you gotta cut the king gotta have it
gotta have that
[Music]
okay still must must cut the king
okay all right g6 get the king to h6
all right i think this is going all
right for
black now just has to be very careful
though
all right let me check to see nope that
person is also done playing i
am running out of players to check
i think this is my least favorite part
of commentating when i'm running out of
players to check
yeah it starts to get a little
nope
[Music]
all right okay you gotta push the pawns
come on come on white
check check check okay
maybe pre-move king h2 okay that works
too
oh gotta play g3 or h3
king f4 there you go that works too now
bring in the king rookie two rookie two
was great too cut the king
okay bring in the rook push the pawn h3
you got this
that works too just gotta push the pawns
careful with still mates oh no
oh no why king e3
why king e3 oh i saw it correctly right
it's just just playing
f king f1 if king g3 king g1
if h3 just came here that's going to be
a still mate
that was a draw oh no
white played so nice got away almost
well this was a very interesting game
yeah these games have so much ups and
downs it's kind of
my eyes scared for my eyes
okay okay let's see how's knock on woods
at kamikaze doing
maybe throwing the e6 around well not
right now but
uh this pawn is really scaring me
oof how did this happen
is this the game where um i was looking
at the knight e4 was
a little too early and i kept saying
should play f4
no that's not the game never mind never
mind this is a completely different game
all right so far everything going good
white is attacking
the center they're taking ah yes this is
the game i was talking with potentially
c4
all right knight g5 interesting oh
that's
usually a bad idea see now black has the
center
completely can start pushing the pawns
this is already a passport over here
whoa and black one by resignation
and i actually don't have any
new games to look at so i gotta scroll
through
a bunch um
nope everybody i'm checking is online
it's actually the set the round two
games finished
or can someone from the team let me know
if
there is one or two games that are still
being played because any game i'm
checking is finished
but i unfortunately don't have
the final results for all the teams
so wow this is going very well
oh boy is it the time that i actually
have to pick a game
oh no i feel
a little pressured
no biggie though can't be hard on
organic chemistry right
i am so glad i'm done with that
ah
no i actually unfortunately i think all
of the games that i am checking
are done
8p
uh
all right i am gonna see if there are
any updates for standings that i could
show
potentially
um all right well
not wish i could show
ah there's a page update
great let me go take a look at that for
the page update
um feeling a little
technologically challenged
ah all right round two will officially
be done
so who's playing that's actually a big
mystery for me right now because
i i've checked all the games that i can
and and so far all of them have been
concluded
oh my cat is pretty pasta actually
that's actually pretty sight
hopefully you guys are cat people even
if you're not you like preferred dogs he
has a very dog-like personality
so you would be quite pleased
all right um i am
hoping that
i'm still looking for players but
in my in my knowledge and my um
extensive copy pasting usernames
everybody is just
online and not playing which means you
guys have finished your games
which is good we ended around a little
faster than expected so
hopefully we're gonna have a standing
soon
and let me just switch the camera
so we have a better a little bit more
focused
view so
yeah this was actually my first time
doing commentary
from home and i usually prefer doing
commentary with someone else
most likely is caleb who's helping or
um there's also ben simon right back
there
in the little studio little control room
helping out too so this has been
a little bit challenging for me i
but yeah it's been it's been a pleasure
i really enjoyed
doing it even with all the challenges
um can't get better if we don't try huh
so i am still waiting on
hopefully standing which
you know what uh
still still waiting or
maybe something wrong from my end
don't see most recent scores
thank you thank you hopefully next time
we do it it will be
in person commentary you guys playing on
boards um i miss playing overboard
chess so
can't wait for that to happen again
um kind of fun fact some some of the
european tournaments have actually
opened up in person
i was actually doing the games of the
week from the beale tournament
in switzerland that are actually holding
in person tournaments
let's see how that goes i'm a little
scared to play in person tournaments
to be completely honest but
i really miss it so hopefully we are
going to be able to
find a cure and just
just play chess online no more online
chess just play like four player chess
online and
real chess overboard yeah
so i
i still can't see scores which is kind
of
um slightly frustrating
let me see if i can help it somehow
um well yeah that's been a very
interesting evening trying to do
commentary from studio d
so just waiting for the final scores oh
i see scores are being updated
lovely
oh we're gonna have a winner soon
thinking about um thinking
yeah i see they're being updated now
thinking about the best game
i i had few that i actually really
enjoyed
um all of them were very interesting but
some of them were were just really
um even more tactical
than i imagined one of the games that i
liked was i'm trying to find that
um was that
this game um the first one that i'm
thinking about
from round one i really enjoyed uh
the first game that um
alex gerford played that was a very
interesting game just everything was so
coordinated that was
the stonewall style that was really
great from round
two i had few that i really liked who
it's kind of hard to pick
i think the the first
one that i really enjoyed was the
the king dennis game versus the
the teacher man that was teacher man
right just
yeah teacher man 22 it was a very
interesting tactical game
i think that was very interesting the
second game from
round two the other game that's um had
the chance to the bishop f3 game was it
this one
yeah this one i i um i also really
enjoyed this one let me
switch back to this this was another
game that i really enjoyed so i'm kind
of
between those three games might need
some help voting oh boy
i think this game i think the all three
games where
those three are like definitely my top
three choices
but i think this one because it had a
lots of ups and downs hold on
no i'm gonna go for sorry for the false
alarm
i am going for um
the game between king dennis and the
teacher man that game um white played
flawlessly the second game
if i could actually find it oh boy
that's going to be pretty impossible
all the games are finished so but that
was
yeah that was that would be my choice
um
yep i picked the game wasn't that hard
now was it
uh yeah i'm i
am unable to actually find that game but
yeah i'm going for that game there were
a lot of great games
a lot of interesting ups and downs but
that game would be this game i was
really between this these three games
but just if the last like in this game
if um this was the game that i was
watching
that we were watching about i kept
saying katy king got the king
this game would have actually just the
last moment when white kind of slipped
away
here over here just boy just
can't get one oh boy can you have one if
king is one
then white then the pawn can never be a
queen right
and if king f1 king g3 just king g1
and you just move your king back here
and that pawn also is can't be a queen
this one game was really great oh it's
really hard to choose all right
i've made my choice and as previously
stated i'm going with king dennis versus
the teacher man but this was a very
close
call so i am gonna go double check to
see if there oops
if there are any um
if i have the scores available
for stream i guess they're updating
slowly
i guess the scores for the round drive
is available but
not uh sorry the players scores are
available but i don't think the
the team score is available
right away
or ah it's updating i see it's updating
whoa
so so far from what i see edwards jones
is
still leading i'm going to come back
over here and
switch to there
so yeah this is quite interesting now
um edward jones is leading
i thought there were more points
ah well uh matthew connors that was a
very great game
good job so uh
oh i yeah i thought edward jones has had
more points than 40 but
whoa almost twice that is well i'm happy
that
um number six and seven got
to actually get higher scores
i i knew you guys could get into
the second digits
so good job on that little hard start
but
nothing that you couldn't come back from
and yeah well this has been very
interesting so edward jones
won the matches today with 60
and half points uh buyer got
second place with 33 and a half points
enterprise uh got third very closed
very close to very close to the second
runner-up
um and ended up with 29 point half
points mark
martz got 26 points half
and
fourth place same as wwt
express scripts got 16 points
and doubt doubtery
oh boy my pronunciation
eventually at some point i'll manage it
13 and a half points and
i'd like to say again it's been a
pleasure
doing this hopefully next time will be
even better than the first time so
always first time streaming is
a little scary but well went alright
slight technical difficulties this has
been very
pleasant thank you guys for making this
happen
and hope you have a great rest of your
day
bye